hi I'm Johanna and I'll be talking to
you guys about the evolution of the
Internet in 1958 the United States
government created the Advanced Research
Projects Agency otherwise miss ARPA to
counter the launching of the Russian
satellite sputnik into space its mission
was to be at the forefront of
technological innovation nearly 10 years
later ARPANET was born ARPANET was a
computer network composed of four
different nodes spread across california
and utah in the following years other
government agencies such as the
Department of Energy and NASA created
their own networks by 1985 the internet
was broadly supported not only by
researchers and developers but also by
the general public using it for daily
communications today more than two
billion people across the world use the
internet and that number continues to
rise information traverses the world at
lightning speeds is changing our sectors
such as business commerce education and
research are taking place today mobile
internet use is becoming increasingly
popular and is also becoming a priority
and Internet technology development so
as you can see the Internet has changed
dramatically over the last 50 years